Esta es una de las rutas que conducen a
las poblaciones aledañas donde la
batalla que se libró en sus calles ha
terminado pero los combates continúan
con intensidad en las regiones que la
rodean
estamos en una contraofensiva
lo que hacemos es ir hacia sus
posiciones los expulsamos y las ocupamos
estos hombres pertenecen a la brigada 57
que hace parte de la contraofensiva
lanzada por el ejército ucraniano que es
de hace dos semanas Busca retomar los
alrededores de la ciudad
su artillería trabaja intensamente es
precisa
Julia Que invita a buscar refugio en el
sótano
subrigado opera en el norte de bakmut
cuentan que los últimos días han
avanzado al menos dos kilómetros en
dirección a la ciudad
Esto es lo que queda de Back mood
todo está destruido Ellos están atacando
continuamente Tan pronto como Ven a
nuestros hombres en el campo o
trincheras atacan por eso es importante
la artillería si no hace su trabajo no
esta Infantería no puede lograr ningún
objetivo en los 10 meses que duró la
batalla esta brigada ha sido enviada a
defender en dos ocasiones la última las
afueras de la ciudad para que los
ucranianos no fueran encerrados
pero han pagado un alto precio humano
las pérdidas son muy dolorosas pero
tengo la confianza de que ha valido la
pena
el objetivo ofensiva es encerrar las
tropas enemigas en Back mood en lo que
los generales ucranianos han llamado
el trabajo que hacemos ahora mismo
podría hacer pensar que estamos
realizando una ofensiva pero lo que
hacemos Es empujar al enemigo para
tratar de encerrarlos allá dentro de
donde se sostienen
sostuvimos su avance lo máximo que
pudimos y ahora intentamos atacar Yo
pienso que será para ellos como un hueso
atravesado en la garganta el tiempo dirá
si Ucrania logró reversar la estrategia
en la vida y encerrar a las tropas rusas
en la histórica